Hm. You know,
I bet you're curious what the stuff you're learning has to do with real design.
We've talked about affordances and signifiers and a little bit about conceptual
models. Well, here's some real design. Let's, let's talk about it. See
this? It's a tape dispenser. And we have the tape [SOUND] something designed
at the end so it doesn't stick. And the holder, the dispenser and look at
this. The packaging. The designer has to think
it all through. It isn't enough to design
the product. You have to design how
it's mounted, the packaging, instruction manuals, even the
box in which it shipped. That's kind of
what's exciting about design, it's the whole system.